les actions de l'Iran ont choqué le
monde civilisé a été saisi et plus
de 60 citoyens américains doivent être
retenus en otages si nous allons y aller
alors nous devons y aller maintenant
ce qui s'est passé six des otages sont
sortis par une sortie arrière où sont les  La
maison des ambassadeurs canadiens a des
gardiens de la révolution qui font du porte-à-porte ces gens
meurent ils meurent mal La Maison Blanche qui veut que
les six sortent ce que nous aimons pour
cela ce sont des vélos livrent les six octets
leur fournissent des cartes ou vous pouvez simplement
envoyer des roues  et les rencontrer à
la frontière avec Gatorade il va falloir
un miracle pour les faire sortir mon homme j'ai
une idée
qu'ils sont une équipe de tournage canadienne pour un
film de science-fiction je vole à Téhéran
nous volons tous ensemble en tant qu'équipe de tournage dont j'ai
besoin  toi pour m'aider à faire un faux film donc
tu veux venir à Hollywood agir comme un
grand coup sans rien faire
ouais tu iras bien dans le scénario
Fargo science fantasy aventure Lois
Kate déserts de Mars ils ont besoin d'un
endroit exotique pour  tirez vous avez besoin d'un producteur si
je fais un faux film ça va être un
faux succès c'est de loin la meilleure mauvaise idée que nous
ayons monsieur
vous avez 72 heures pour obtenir l'objet
qu'ils reçoivent un visiteur vous avez fait sortir les
gens de cette façon  avant
non, ils nous demandent de vous faire confiance avec
nos vies c'est ce que je fais et je n'ai
jamais laissé personne derrière
je sais qu'ils le sont et ils savent qu'ils se
cachent c'est fini pour moi ils restent
ici ils seront probablement pris  pas
vivants nous sommes responsables de ces gens
je suis responsable
tu crois vraiment que tes petites histoires
vont faire une différence quand il y a un
pistolet sur la tempe je pense que ma petite histoire
est la seule chose entre toi et un pistolet
sur la tempe
toi